the wood
did you know that 2020 is the most
important election of our lifetimes
if not this election is the most
important
in the modern history of this country i
think it's the most important election
of our lifetimes this is a life-changing
election
you get up and you create a crowd
[Music]
people need to start taking to the
streets this is a dictator
i just don't even know why there aren't
uprisings all over the country
you know there needs to be unrest in the
streets we will punch
some people in the face
they go low we kick
republican house majority whip steve
scalise
they're still going to have to go out
and put a bullet in donald trump
this is the most important election
in the history of our country
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
subject for today
[Music]
well then
thank you for being with us uh my half
page and lawyer bill richmond is in the
house
hello you know he'd be here because we'd
be talking big tech
and uh i'm just making up for
quarterback air not being here audio
way too cute maddie on overlays i threw
up in my mouth a little she's so cute
that it just
well and i don't i don't by the way
she's single is she single i don't care
we'll make sure that gotta keep the
mystery alive
she's single boys and looking she's on
the prowl
uh how are you geraldine fantastic
good still drinking so awkward for her
right now it's not awkward she's like a
little sister who i offer up to strange
men
[Laughter]
um i didn't know you were from
kazakhstan
we have a lot to get to today we're
going to be talking about youtube's new
fact checking feature i want to know how
many of you have run into that
uh we'll be talking about biden's
backers we will be talking about acb
and the meltdown that ensued but first i
want to present this
story to you okay don't go to the clip
yet i'll tell you when to go to the clip
we have uh sorry tim from hr quarterback
garrett uh
i i want to say our thoughts and prayers
of them his uh his child took a little
bit of a spill a tumble from what i
understand will be okay but he's been in
the hospital
so godspeed and uh put a put
nerf your house just quarter black
garrett cover it up
put a leather helmet on the children it
it serves two
it keeps them safe and it keeps other
people away
so this story the way it was presented
on cnn this morning
verbatim was protests erupt in
philadelphia today after police
killed and shot a black man now let me
provide some actual context here
uh yes protests did erupt they did it's
almost like you need more
ah tell us more it's almost is it tell
me more
tell me more like did he have a knife
[Laughter]
did he put up a fight how crazy would it
be if a black guy in the wrong area
philly was like
tell me more tell me more i almost
stabbed your cop ass
no you just i just in the musicals and i
hate cops
it's a crossover it's kind of my calling
card uh
know that's actually gonna be a hit on
broadway yeah this is gonna be a hit on
broadway right now it's gonna be
hamilton
it's like no but i'm i'm hamilton but
not that hamilton i'm the hamilton who
sings tunes
and stabs cops i just happen to be named
hamilton
as well i understand where the confusion
arose so there were there have been
protests in philadelphia
and uh police did shoot a uh black man
now
the black man in question was walter
wallace jr and uh police were responding
to
a call about a man with a knife and he
charged at the police officers
with an eye for those who have not seen
the clip i warn you it may be disturbing
but here is what actually transpired
[Applause]
oh my god oh my god
bro they just killed them in front of me
yo now if you watch that video and your
first instinct is
burn down in o'reilly's auto parts the
problem is you
jesus let's be really clear that guy was
clearly charging cops
with a knife and people saying the cops
didn't do anything to de-escalate what
do you do when a guy is charging you
with a knife and here's something else
that i think people need to take into
context
we all have for i was talking with the
audio wait before the show we all have
relatives who maybe have acted out for
let's say a relative who maybe was an
alcoholic or a domestic abuser we had
someone who we
sort of had witnessed swatting around
their child a distant relative
oh my gosh we don't know what this
person is capable of so we didn't trust
them around anybody
yeah right because once someone crosses
that line well what do you think
is a prohibition for any action for
walter wallace jr if he's willing to
charge police officers with a knife
where does he draw that line
as far as i'm concerned someone who
charges at cops with a knife
with the intent to attack them as you
clearly see there that is someone
who cannot be trusted to be anything
other than violent
at all times yeah they gave him more
time than i would have
right me or you on the street and
somebody's coming at us with a knife and
we have a firearm
they were backing up back creating space
which is what they're supposed to do
they said they didn't do anything to
de-escalate yes they did they gave him
time to make a better decision which he
refused to make
right and they created space between
them they gave him verbal commands to
drop the knife if he had dropped the
knife and kept walking probably wouldn't
have gotten shot
people saying are the same people who
say shoot them the leg right right by
that
potentially your future president i mean
this is a situation where
it's in broad daylight they can see
what's going on and this gentleman
didn't just
you know he wasn't just standing there
and he's being arrested and maybe he
reached for his pocket or looked like he
was reaching for his pocket
he moved around a vehicle towards them
with a knife while they're shooting at
him while other people are shouting at
him to stop
and they're backing away and taking this
action i mean there's just there's just
no question that i i think that
anyone who criticizes this is is really
saying oh well uh
he was just going to threaten with it or
he was just going to use the tip just
the flesh
yeah just the tip to see just a tip to
see if it kills
so yeah it is yeah he wasn't reaching
into his pocket the knife had already
he wasn't like doublemint that's not
what happened i want to be really clear
about this if they're going to protest
and riot over this
listen then there's no scenario in which
you believe it's true you believe in
completely defunding the police if you
don't believe that police
have the right to defend themselves and
of course people in the community by the
way
people of color women of color we didn't
care about that with jacob blake right
it doesn't matter they committed sexual
assault because uh at this point this is
uh the victim du jour which isn't even
just people of color as people who
happen to get shot by cops regardless of
whether or not they sexually abuse
other people of color and in this
scenario if you don't think that a cop
has a right to defend themselves in the
mean charge with a knife
okay you believe in totally defunding
the police that is your stance and i
tell you what though
they continue rioting and looting and it
makes it way out to lancaster with the
amish again
bye-bye pennsylvania we're already
seeing the polls coming in you have a
guy who said he's going to
ban all not just fracking all fossil
fuels and now they're going to start
rioting and protesting the only reason
black lives matter went away
was because the dnc had had a talk with
them and he said this is showing up
remember don lemon it's showing up in
the polls
what polls you haven't seen those polls
you say all the polls are great yeah
absolutely but all those protests are
totally organic
uh yes they're peaceful completely
organized mostly peaceful
no fires behind me protest by the way do
we know why they were called out there
is is that out yet i believe they were
called because of a man wielding a knife
oh okay so i don't at the time of this
broadcast i don't know for certain we do
know that he had a knife there as you
can see in that video right so here
here's the trade-off right if this
is outside of the bounds for you a cop
being able to defend their own life to
make sure they go home to their wife and
kids that night or their husband
then they're just not going to come when
you call them with a man with a knife on
the street they'll be like well hey guys
sorry we can't come for that because if
we have to defend ourselves you're going
to try and kill us
yeah well no they want to call a social
worker who could go up and ask him about
his mom
let's talk you know what you know i
really want to know is how many social
workers are like
yeah yeah i wanted to be in that
situation yeah right you know i got one
of those like no cut gloves that you use
in the kitchen
you know i've got two of those i'm gonna
pull those out of my knapsack and then
you know make sure i also cover face
shield because covid right did we yeah
yeah and uh we're not we're not animals
he's peaceably talk to this guy
you know make him see that about his
mother did your mother also uh attempt
to stab police officers with a knife
oh interesting oh that's one for you
wallace from the family i guess
the cops yell out yeah your self-esteem
seems low today
you'll never take me left so what are
you saying uh i think he said that
someone corrected
his final exam with a red pen a red pen
this is a red pen scenario
his self-esteem is all awry uh
i don't think i've told you guys the
story but one time i was representing a
federal judge asked me to represent
an inmate in a pro bono civil case and i
did and he had to come from jail for his
deposition
marshall's brought him out and set him
down he's still in chains the entire
time
and during one of the breaks i'm sitting
next to my client defending you know
objecting uh to the deposition questions
they're being asked by the prosecutor
and one of the marshals pulls me aside
during the break he goes hey
do whatever you want to do but i would
just recommend that you not
put your pens or pencils near your
client
not saying he's a bad guy i'm just
saying i've seen it twice
a lawyer gets stabbed by his client with
his own pen
and i was just trying to perform
a tracheotomy because my half-assed
lawyer got more of a flat face
he was just trying to make sure i could
breathe but but that's how quickly
things can change
and we don't realize that we are so
fortunate that we have these officers
out there to take the yeah involuntary
tricky but here's the lower third on cnn
yeah let's let's go to cnn really
quickly listen protester up in
philadelphia
please fatally shoot black men just like
listen that's already a pretty lengthy
lower third could you just add knife
wielding
yeah exactly would it kill you to add
knife wheeling in there
like that matters this goes to show you
again everything it's going to be a long
dark winter
oh my we have a we're going to have a
downturn economy unemployment's going to
go up
look cops are still racist they need you
to be terrified to vote for them a vote
for donald trump is a vote saying hey
you know what we're not perfect but
i still think this is actually a pretty
damn good country we've done pretty well
before this pandemic a vote for
democrats is i don't believe there's any
hope in this country
outside of our lord and savior biden
christ
now uh of course uh protesters because
you know 48
48 years 49th the charm
uh protesters of course they reacted
with what we have a montage of
protesters going to protest
[Music]
oh oh my god he hit a guy
they ran that lady right over you know
what we never talk about in this country
too those protests like oh this is the
voice of the unheard
that guy was definitely grabbing more
than he needed why don't we talk about
greed from people
who also create nothing we talk about
greed with people who are wealthy sure
is that guy not a greedy prick just i'm
gonna grab all these shoes but those are
size nine and you're a 13. i don't give
a [ __ ]
what do you think i mean what do you
think these people they're just hoarding
hoarding going in there and stealing
from another business owner that is
complete and total unfettered greed why
do we only why do we only
use that attack against wealthy people
of course it's a it's a valid criticism
these are greedy people who are taking
advantage
we want we want to get mad at people for
price gouging in a natural disaster
how about just actual theft taking
things that you don't need
i don't understand how robbing a store
is now the way to end depression when
the store is
likely black owned black employed people
working at the store in your own
community like when did this become the
thing
those five pairs of nikes are gonna make
things okay
right and the other person in there she
said they ain't got no socks it won't
make it okay
but it'll make it better no it won't
maybe don't make it into me baby steps
and i'm gonna be taking baby steps in my
new kicks [ __ ]
so another story moving on to
better news the first murder hornet uh
nest was killed yesterday in washington
state
on the united states canada border
japanese killer hornets what they should
be called
they got him uh no the b the queen d
was still there whoa
so actually uh we do our part here at
leadership a lot of people don't know
that even brendan is um a qualified
entomologist
so even brennan come on in here we're
going to be having him uh today educate
us a little bit on japanese killer
hornets and uh he'll be
searching for them how are you even
brendan i'm good i'm good yeah
that's not covering your face at all no
well it will be okay good yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah there you go
okay so what do you plan on we're going
to be sending you out to try and find
some of these murder hornets because
yeah it's another pandemic right now
what do you think you'll be encountering
uh well bees they have nests that can
cover of like
50 000 bees in one nest so there's going
to be a lot
there's going to be a lot that are kind
of scattered about they're not all in
the nest at the same time
so it's going to be kind of a task to
get them all accounted for
uh bees can fly 20 miles per hour so you
can't really outrun them
these are all beef they have yeah yeah
we're sending you off
for murder hornets very different as a
matter of fact they threaten the
the bee population well that's pretty
close right yeah you know it's close
enough all right well go out there
use your tubes and your jar yeah and
we'll check back in with you later
okay thank you even brendan those are
some interesting defects they are
interesting
the more you know i think this is where
i would say from a legal standpoint
objection irrelevant
and i hope we have an insurance policy
on professor brendan
i don't know if it covers murder hornets
i think it covers japanese killer
hornets before we whitewash the name
uh all right we're gonna move on here to
the censorship acb but first uh please
do subscribe if you are not on
apple podcasts uh android wherever you
listen to audio
only because it's also available there
every monday and thursday yeah and we'll
be taking your live chat when we go
exclusive to mug club
after this people who are not yet a
member live with cutter.com and of
course our big election live stream four
year anniversary of mug club
we will have a very steep discount uh on
election night okay
so my question is we all know about
facebook and twitter right we all know
horrible horrible
horrible people horrible platforms uh
leading
leading not even questions tables we all
agree right
that's a summary but have you guys
actually encountered the youtube
fact-checking uh new device that they
have up there
we have helpful fact checks but then
we've been fact checked on the when
we've when then their facts have changed
so we were fact checked on being right
first
so it's like it's like the uh the
inception
of shitty fact check yeah so we're gonna
be talking about that but first
acv was confirmed yes she was confirmed
big victory uh for white males justice
and the leftists have i'm happy about it
i'm very happy
you know i'm happy about it gerald's
happy about it bill's less happy about
it yeah yeah yeah
cute maddie is furious enough ah that's
true well look i did think it was pretty
ridiculous that you know you had a
privileged male
you know making sure that a privileged
white person was sworn in i mean that's
what i'm pretty sure the cnn
right yeah by whom right it's like oh
what what is there
any other characteristic you want to
just check box there are progressives
and democrats about
these people who are doing this thing
well you know it would have been great
if clarence thomas came out and took him
from he just like came out with lipstick
and rouge
[Laughter]
he just came out like [ __ ] i'm clarita
put your hand on the bible
yeah then we could have checked all the
boxes so of course people are freaking
out want to give you the highlights of
the best freakouts because
it's going to be handmade uh handmaiden
or handmade still handmade
mates handmaid's tale yeah uh here's one
from a tick-tock
uh broad who um well just let's let's
just cycle through these it's just
entertainment
i'm in the bath but while i've been here
i got a notification
amy cody parent was
officially can you plug in your phone
and drop it
but i'm scared someone throw a blow
dryer in there
other women people
who need help everyone except white men
that's like uh that episode of the
office when smokey robinson
ryan thought that he did yeah they're
like name me one song can you name me
one
policy name me one vote a dissenting
opinion from rbg
any just pick one give me one well i'm
too busy in my uh
hot tub okay well we understand
it's like sad asmr
[Laughter]
looks like a drowned mouse and here's
another one
uh from an angry and by the way this is
just one whenever someone is doing the
talking like this you know that's
they're crazy
yeah they're crazy we saw that before
with the lady who was bitching about uh
donald trump and chris crocker was
talking about like britney spears and
leave her alone
you know so uh yeah
uh here's this uh uh uh queer queer
queer
thing queer z queer being reaction day
cb
amy connie barrett was just confirmed to
the supreme court
um all those times i said i was queer
oh my god you guys that was so funny
high school drama teacher
a total joke oh my god i was just
kidding
all those times i said men don't deserve
rights oh my god men are so great i need
i need a husband to show me how to
be an adult how to function how about
starting with a dad
dumb woman no no numbers
everything's fine not insanity
but we can get you a straight jacket
pretty soon there really is a
derangement syndrome here
really the most offensive part of that
is how unfunny it's like pick a lane are
you being ironic are you being sarcastic
are you being a character
you're just a lazy queer you're just a
lazy
queen just not good comedy at all and i
said cause she said queer
she she did yeah which i don't even know
what that means i think i think that
i think that girl just wants to keep the
mystery alive yeah like with maddie
being single maddie's not queer she's
straight
not queer but she is single not that
there's anything wrong with that
and i'm pretty sure that that other lady
is single but for entirely different
reasons
she does need someone to show her how to
live i'm not sure if it's a husband i'm
not sure any willing candidates are out
there
but nonetheless a husband would help are
we just going to be a social worker
i don't understand how they can
unironically talk about how
having a woman who has been successful
by every measure
ever created by either side up down left
right center
acb is super super successful and yet
the people who are attacking her the
most
are white women yes i know right i know
well she's like she's like a disney film
in a good way where she like comes home
from fighting cases in the supreme court
and like
oh what will i make and it's like it's a
commercial for digerno like thank god
for rising crust
turns out i can do it all thanks to
giorno that
is and by the way digerno send us a
check that is
[Laughter]
what acb is and it infuriates the left
like most most you cannot have all
things you can't
typically be the career woman and also
be the kind of mom that you want to have
the kind of time with your children that
you want
but if you look at the decisions that
she's made throughout her life it is
she's about as close as you get yeah
then most importantly she's fine
go ahead she has destroyed everything
they thought they couldn't do
they're like well no i've got to have
just a career so i'll have the abortion
and so i can focus on my career and
you're like oh well hey look i'm a
supreme court justice i was a professor
at the university of notre dame i was on
the seventh circuit court of appeals
right and i have seven
kids and i'm doing this all yeah good
luck
i am i am a queer drama
phd student and i
cannot be and i don't need someone i had
to have an abortion because it was the
most
pain i didn't have time in my life it's
like yeah okay well i actually have uh
seven children i've adopted so is it
seven children that she has or five
children
i've now been appointed to the supreme
court i was on the seventh circuit court
but your thing sounds
it sounds tough too you know what the
normal time you got a full day this is
the same tactic that joe biden said when
he said
you know that you ain't black right
right they they count on
the box checking characteristics but as
soon as someone breaks the mold on the
narrative that they want to use about
how everyone's oppressed by
republicans conservatives trump you know
mitch mcconnell whatever
then they just go oh you must not be
part of the protected group
right you must no longer be one of the
anointed you are no longer
a woman who worked hard who balanced
everything and achieved
one of the most highest and respected
positions not just in the country in the
entire world yeah
and and so you must not be that person
you must be someone else
you ain't black you ain't a woman and to
be fair we need to tighten up the
patriarchy a little bit because
we've been letting some slip through the
crowd i know yeah if we're if we are the
patriarchy and in control we're doing a
terrible journey we have not done
very well we need a meeting the only
diversity that they want is superficial
diversity any
diversity beyond skin level yeah that's
that's the nasty stuff that's the stuff
you got to kick those people
you don't count unless you don't believe
in your guys though please you don't
count unless you are
queer and then depending on black
remember we went we had black lives
matter was the thing for a while
and then when okay uh donald trump went
to the [ __ ] hat that was really big and
then we went to the trans thing where
they could take dumping targets and that
they should be allowed in the same
barracks in the military and then we
went back to like you know what let's go
back to the black thing and then someone
said hey hello
some of these people who are talking
about who are kind of turning into
martyrs they sexually assaulted
women like no no that was me me too
we're done with that we're now in the
black thing we're done with that like oh
but but
doesn't all of this matter uh patriarchy
but we just appointed a woman
[Laughter]
just wandering around in the background
speaking of oppressed reza aslan i
believe former cnn contributor you know
he he said that uh he threatened to burn
the entire effing thing down if they
tried to replace
whatever that means and then people you
know they they brought up his tweet
again
and uh and said are you still planning
on this so dinesh d'souza was one of
them and then he demanded publicly
dinesh d'souza's address
wow no i don't know if that's like if he
wants to if he wants to get an early
start in his valentine
or if he is violating twitter's uh terms
of service by
attempting to dox or attempting to get
someone to reveal private information
and yeah the obvious insinuation is that
he wants to burn dinesh d'souza's house
down
right wow no no he's just like the guy
with the knife
he was just trying to genuinely display
you know his fine knife and bladed
weapons collection
yeah that's it he's just a traveling
ginsu salesman yeah no problem
and he's so well balanced he's gonna
look
do the just he's gonna do the little
show-and-tell for dinesh he's like i
don't want you to cut the penny that's
my penny it was a useful penny
that's a legal tender and a knife in one
hand and a melon in the other
he's like it's winter winter's coming
you need you need fire i'm just i'm
going to show them the fire
right oh the fire burns your whole
family well you know what
let's what buy guns be buy guns um and
another one now this uh just
might the worst the worst absolute worst
senator i think in the in the country
um that's tough too yeah yeah it's tough
to do uh
hirono uh when voting when they were
doing the vote
on acb uh take a listen to what she said
she made she went out of her way to be
emphatic about voting no
miss cinema ms smith miss stavenow
yeah and that made the rounds everywhere
a lot of controversy
um because some would say it's
unbecoming [ __ ] but that's actually
not
what got her in trouble a lot of people
don't realize because they get
context matters they cut the clip there
was more to it than that
why she got in trouble miss cinema miss
smith
miss stavenow
i you know whoa the sex drive is
incomparable i can't believe we didn't
pick that up earlier
we don't want to shame women for listen
have a healthy drive
[Music]
but on the senate floor exactly there's
a time and a place
for loving a long time you know i don't
think she's not doing a lot here to like
you know
quash the q and on conspiracies giving
she's invoking hell
anyways i mean you know death called
hell no no
this is this is my one thing i'm gonna
throw out to manny that this entire year
that's it annie that's your one
wait i don't think the vial of blood
around her neck helped either no
no no also she's 190 because if you have
an asian woman who looks that she's like
70 like she does yeah she is at least
200 years well i don't know i think she
breaks she's like she's like an asian
benjamin button
oh yeah wow she's just because her soul
is yeah exactly
she's two she looks shockingly old for
two
this explains the questioning of it yeah
like how old are you are you like
64. she's like no i two
i never would have guessed hirono nobody
checks the id yeah
so um let's move on now to
i was gonna see it see has anyone
noticed that cnn is all commercials now
it's like nine minutes of commercials
stop current inviters can run a various
current advisors trump is bad commercial
and they were spending money on don't uh
one lady saying if acb becomes supreme
court justice i was watching this
morning she's to ban my ivf
first off no second why was there an
anti-acb
ad on cena like how are these packs
wasting their money yeah it's too late
right like is there a swing state that
didn't you just have your major
candidate say that he was going to
end all fossil fuels which is the
bedrock of the economy
of arguably the most important state in
the election you want people to [ __ ]
about ivf
on anderson cooper like if this is where
you're spending your money
yeah on second thought please continue
spending your money there and not
helping joe biden confirmed
it's actually next monday right he's
running those ads
and election is uh it's next year
next yeah not this year it's actually
our bad it's january 24th it's kova just
messed everything up yeah it's true it's
like the olympics it's just postponed
speaking of fact checking uh youtube so
this is something we know that twitter
facebook are awful but have you guys
this is my question you have you
personally encountered the fact
checking tab the little pop-up with
videos on youtube
because this is something that's been
going on for a while and we've had our
conversations with youtube but this is
something that uh
i would say just kind of like the the
last debate i thought
um that i forgot her name the name of
the female who was not savannah guthrie
the other one uh
welcome she was worse than chris wallace
because she tried to present it as
though she was being objective
this to me is worse and this is the
person who was the catalyst for the vox
apocalypse sorry
this is worse than that because this is
uh
subtle it's pervasive it's it's it's
subversive it's oh well you know what
we're just fact checking is what we're
doing we're
we're sending you to a truthful source
but again
the the problem is just like anesthesia
talked about in the shows
the measure of freedom of a country the
same thing on these platforms
considering that they say they are open
platforms
is whether the rules are applied
equally yeah and i don't think i've seen
a more blatant abuse of fact checking
than uh youtube with these new little
pop-ups so let's go through a couple of
them here's number one
fracking if you search biden fracking on
youtube okay youtube adds a fact check
yeah that's right there we have it on
the overlay
that says uh from snopes where they say
that it's mostly false
that biden would ban fracking right
that's what you so youtube has that
pop-up if you type in biden
fracking you didn't even say biden ban
biden fracking ah it's mostly false well
not only is that not true but even the
people who really want it to be not true
have had to admit that it is entirely
true cue
uh dwight shoot on cnn in this case
trump is correct biden did make
anti-fracking comments
during the democratic primary 2019 and
2020. and trump was not lying
listen for example to something he said
in 2019
there be any place for fossil fuels
including coal
and fracking in a biden administration
no we would we would work it out we
would make sure it's eliminated and no
more subsidies
for either one of those either any
fossil fuel this is mostly false
i mean my god that was so clear
there's so many more videos we've run
montages on this show uh here's the
irony
is you can fact check youtube's fact
check by just searching for the videos
on youtube
now you won't find them right away right
you'll have to use some kind of a
dark web wizardry to actually find the
many clips the dozens of clips of
binding guaranteeing that they'll ban
fracking but youtube is fact checking
themselves i don't know what kind of
legal liability that opens them up to
but oh my god
this is one i don't know if there's a
court in the land even hirono would be
like wow
me so honey but you screwed up
[Music]
it's you know and did you get to the
legal side of it
at one point they were saying okay we
have an immunity that says
we can remove stuff based on good faith
but this isn't about just removing this
is about affirmatively stating
facts and making allegations that are
completely untrue
and just flip-flopping entirely on their
position that they're just going to let
the
let the platforms be what the platforms
are and only remove dangerous material
look we all want to agree that there's a
certain level of material
that does need to be removed right we're
hunter by way
way past that line especially when
they're making these designations and it
was originally just facebook facebook
was the only one
at first doing the false and partially
false and linking to the wrong sources
and the wrong fact checkers
a bunch of fact checkers that are like
hiding out behind a planned parenthood
you know eating out of the dumpster
i mean they weren't eating they were
making soap
well you were correct yeah thank you for
packing but no you're absolutely right
and this is one of those things
i said when it happened on election
night i said oh biden may have just lost
the election yeah he talked when it was
fracking and donald trump
oh that's a good statement are you
listing pennsylvania there's a reason
that this
is one where they're the most aggressive
again if you type in the variance of
biden fracking fracking biden biden
fossil fuel energy
try just try a nice little sampling like
a sherry's berries
of [ __ ] and see what youtube does
it's because they know that right now
the polls are shifting in pennsylvania
and donald trump has created a new block
of undecided voters who plan on voting
for biden going
i know i'm going to lose my job which is
also why we shouldn't have early voting
for
anyone and everyone because things
change leading up to election day
how many people do you think in
pennsylvania after hearing that biden is
going to ban
their livelihood outright how many of
them do you think i wish i didn't vote
four days ago
i wish i could have just sauntered on
down to the grade school day of and
and give this guy the old heave-ho
instead
we want everyone to vote as early as
possible and that's also something no
one's talking about you know why because
last election hillary clinton lost it
very close to the election yeah
right so biden hides out in the basement
no one sees them no one sees them no one
sees them
when it's time to pay the piper coming
up to election time and he can no longer
ignore the questions
well most people have already voted it's
a problem here's another one another
fact check is uh if you search
biden so i want everyone to do this
right now and by the way you can use
expressvpn one of our wonderful sponsors
expressvpn.com uh it's okay we don't
have a plug or commercial for them i
just love expressvpn
uh if you search biden xenophobic
youtube right there tells you that by
never called trump xenophobic okay now
this is one
this is one i want to be clear in the
spirit of
um balance
there's nuance let's bring up the biden
tweet because it said he's just he
called no he called he said stop being a
zenophobic
fear-mongering uh and and by the way the
context there matters because he said it
in response to donald trump's travel ban
so the nuance there is you just need to
actually read joe biden's tweet
where he called donald trump xenophobic
how does youtube justify how do they
i don't understand this how do they even
justify saying oh he didn't call trump
xenophobic because
joe biden tried to be clever and say i
didn't call trump's
travel ban xenophobic i just responded
to his travel ban saying that it was
xenophobic fear-mongering
so really i just called trump xenophobic
but not the ban even though i haven't
responded as to whether i would have
done it
or not and look at me my mask is below
my nose so this is what happens with
biden and even by the way i want to be
really clear
um i think snopes snopes everyone
recognizes that he
did call trump xenophobic oh my gosh
well it's this this thing where biden is
saying no i didn't call him i called the
travel ban and like and then google's
like no no
no he never called him that what are you
talking about it never even happened
this is
a video isn't this like the argument
used in the backseat with your sibling
yeah
i didn't i didn't call him stupid i just
said what he did was stupid
right oh i okay right so that's
so stupid except you just say stop being
stop what do you say stop being he's not
the xenophobic stop the xenophobe but
then he was asked to get into the debate
he said i do think he's xenophobic
remember that he double down on it yeah
he definitely does not once
but twice xenophobic apparently looks
like youtube you know what you'd be
better off your faction
make it the higher the count
two two double down on [ __ ]
xenophobic just stay out of this
business altogether you guys are not
good at this and you're not doing it
right even if you're trying your hardest
which we know you're not you're just
lying right
you're doing a horrible job a horrible
disservice to people who are just trying
to find information
going into an election that's very
important can you get the hell out of
the way please what point is this
election meddling
where joe biden called donald trump
xenophobic joe biden said he would ban
fracking
youtube is saying that that's not true
it is true he said those things you can
find those things
at what point is this election meddling
we're mad about ten thousand dollars
from russia and three thousand ads by
the way putin said that the democratic
party is more in sync
with communist russia but they are
just think about how many things think
about how many free ads and exposure
are given by this fake fact check right
again it's not just
oh biden said ban fracking and now
you're going to provide an additional
link
it's any combination of the words on
this topic at all
right results and i'm curious to see
what the numbers of searches are for
that and the number of times people are
seeing
these free ads right in the lead up to
one of the most important elections in
our history that's a good point yeah and
it would be nice if they were
transparent about it which is something
that i think open platforms should
probably be
hey who are the fact checkers well we
don't know hey who are the ones who
decide what's advertiser friendly well
it's not us well who are they well we
can't tell you hey who decides the
guidelines well that's us what are the
guidelines we don't know
oh so you're not a real thing
is there video evidence on your platform
by the way i hit the notification bell
speaking of youtube
because subscriptions don't mean a whole
lot anymore i don't know what
subscriptions actually
do uh but a notification lets you know
every time we're live uh
weekday mornings at 10 a.m eastern and
of course we have the mega live stream
starting next tuesday election night
with i think we have ted cruz
donald trump jr uh i should and you
specified donald trump jr because
and now he's great too and we have all
kinds of guests all kinds of games
someone here is going to be shot in a
bulletproof vest because
wow not a fake it will actually happen
tune in on tuesday
number three here's another fact check
if you search on youtube right now and i
want you all to search
use your little fingers if you search
obama if you are or in case if you are a
feminist just smash the keypad with your
palm
because that's your best bet then record
a cell phone video in your car
june 18th so if you search on youtube
right now obama spied on trump campaign
or you could type in obama spied on the
trump campaign
or did obama spy on the campaign yeah
you know give it your own little zest
youtube adds a fact check telling you
that no they didn't here's the truth
not only did the justice department find
that obama uh
the wiretap uh from this is from the fbi
too the wiretap
happened but they also did it without
justification
oh this is from the justice department
from the fbi people who don't really
like donald trump by the way a lot of
these folks the people who are banging
down doors like donald trump the people
at the desks
not so much very often there have been
some there's been some friction
a little bit so matt imagine this right
now right we're just we've just gone
through three
if you were to search on youtube hey did
biden say let's say you're in
pennsylvania and you're undecided you're
one of those undecided voters who's
oversampled by like 92 percent
in some of these polls like i don't know
i live in pennsylvania do i want my
economy crushed
did biden say he would ban fracking no
okay well that's not true
okay i'm not a far-left ideologue i
think donald trump seems like i don't
like his his policies but i think he's a
decent guy i don't think he's xenophobic
i probably would have a problem with a
candidate who does the identity politics
did joe biden call him xenophobic no
youtube says no
oh wait hold on a second you know donald
trump is he's sort of anti-elitist and
he claims that there's this big scandal
where
obama wiretapped his campaign i mean now
if that's not true
then donald trump is crazy is there any
evidence oh youtube says no
the number one most viewed multimedia
website in the world
says no when all evidence that we have
including
documented video evidence and statements
from law enforcement agencies and intel
say
yes you don't think that can affect the
election here's another one
uh it's not it it's also by the way it's
important too i have a few of them but
it's important to note it's not just the
fact checks that are incorrect
but it's uh not including fact checks
when even their partners who they
reference but they're like snopes
rate biden is false so they're selective
and they're fact checking
in one scenario snopes or politifact is
legitimate and then in the other they're
just not included at all
and that's what's again is it applied
equally and in this case we have such a
clear-cut case because the same fact
checker even on
on one says you know what we're gonna
have to give this to them this one's
true
just a blackout from youtube so here's
another example on that uh biden claimed
on multiple occasions that trump told
people to drink
or to inject bleach youtube doesn't
include a fact check at all so if you
type that in
nothing donald trump joe biden trump
injecting bleach ingesting bleach type
in your variants
nothing politifact one of youtube's
aforementioned
aforementioned fact-checking sites
labeled it as false or the hell's
politifact
well i have to hear at this point
where's the alert system where are the
pinocchios yeah
that's i mean it's just like when we saw
texas laboratory guy on cnn saying yes
he did say the fracking i mean
people are admitting in certain places
but it's not getting amplified
and that's the biggest difference here
is you're seeing for one side
one party one candidate a broad
amplification of fact checks that are
helpful to
him that's it right it's all pro biden i
give them no credit for that by the way
and we have to do we have to pull this
up that fact checker for cnn when he was
asked that question
earlier said you know it's not
necessarily true i'll have to kind of
give something to trump
if you go to his website joe biden
actually says new fracking and new
government leases that was the first
fact check they did
when trump released the video there's
now no doubt cnn has to come back and
clean that up i want to go back and look
and see both of those we can put them
side by side yeah
see how they changed that's the only
thing i think that's the only reason
that we're seeing any of that come out
is because okay if you didn't see the
video from donald trump being you know
tweeting it out or putting it out on his
facebook or whatever you didn't follow
him yeah you wouldn't see it and that's
why big media they're putting pressure
on big tech to try and silence donald
trump and the fact check donald trump so
that's that's this unholy alliance
that's taking place
the vox apocalypse let's be really clear
vox nbc universal okay
that's what the problem was the problem
wasn't me it was nbc universal didn't
like that there was someone out there
who was cleaning their clock and by the
way they also happened to co-produce a
show
with youtube follow the money trail here
and now you have cnn and you have all
these other entities who want to make
sure that they keep a stranglehold on
online content and they can't compete
in the realm of quality why because
while we actually sit here we've just
listed for you i think just today
14 sources that you can go and look up
for yourselves or cnn they have legal
analysts
masturbating on zoom calls so i say that
we offer
more value in our bathrobes
depending on what you're looking for i
guess right now by the way they're
talking on cnn they're doing these zoom
calls and they can't even be bothered to
get an actual microphone
um they're talking about donald trump
and talking about them stumping in swing
swing states yeah
think of how much ground has to be made
up by donald trump
just what we're going through right now
the fact checking not including abc nbc
cnn uh cbs msnbc everything not named
fox news and by the way most of the time
fox news
if this were if they were an honest
press right now or at least a fair press
even just a press that were that were
honest about their own personal biases
this election wouldn't even be close no
the fact that if i searched biden uh is
mine gonna ban fracking
no did he call donald trump xenophobic
no okay the fact that i searched those
and i am lied to by youtube and that
trump is even within the margin of error
should tell you everything you need to
know
about the state of this country they try
to say oh donald trump doesn't really
have
the popular vote well okay let's just
add up the influence you have from big
tech and i think epstein not the
pedophile i've seen the other
yeah so there's like 10 million 12
million votes that are effectively
bought
through the censoring uh that takes
place in big tech another one this one's
important because
people will say oh that's kind of
hearsay and you know biden says stupid
[ __ ]
so maybe he didn't mean what he said
about fracking that's not you can't
really hang him on it because he has
held two positions on every single issue
um i don't you know what i don't allow
that point
i agree with everything that you said
but i don't like you so i won't allow it
uh here's another example of something
very clear because it relates to
economics and the second that biden
wades into that
you can just hear the buttholes and
moderators clench i mean
so biden also claimed that the deficit
with china
went up under trump and if you search
for it on youtube there's no fact check
at all
no faction at all although the youtube
the the youtube trump's campaign right
the video does come up from donald trump
the campaign so i want to be clear about
that
uh good baby steps youtube now the truth
again politifact who they've used in
these other instances
did issue a fact check of this biden was
wrong
biden was wrong the trade deficit did
not go up it was higher under barack
obama it's very clear because there's
a clear-cut financial before and after
so this is what really matters is are
these standards being applied equally
and just think of how
much manipulation is taking place with
this election
and i gotta tell you i do think that
youtube is the most important people
talk about twitter people talk about
facebook sure
unfortunately though youtube has they
have the biggest pockets being google
and
youtube together and it's where people
go to consume media it's not necessarily
interactive
so there's this semblance of some kind
of authority
coming right yeah they think it's an
authoritative source as opposed to their
grandmother you know posting a picture
of prairie dog's testicles on their wall
and below a maga thing you're like yeah
well you but you posted prairie dog's
testicles
so i don't necessarily trust your
political sourcing
yeah uh i think that's a good point i
really do a lot of people do go to
twitter and facebook to find different
stories i used to i usually go there to
find
somebody who's telling me like the on
the ground story so i get it unfiltered
to some degree and now i have fact
checks on both of those but this is like
the last place
the last place that you can go to and
just watch what happened for yourself
right you can hear somebody comment on
it if you want but now you're even
stopped and like hold on
this didn't actually happen and so
people who are on the fence like you
said they're going to go there and go
oh well no they have a fact check there
on my twitter they have a fact check on
on on facebook they have a fact check it
must not be true at all right
it's it's like it's like the person who
just sits there quietly for a long time
doesn't say anything one way or the
other and then when they do say
something everyone's like oh
well i guess that must be true they
waited to say something right facebook
has been doing this for a long time
everyone's discrediting their fact
checking no one really believes twitter
about anything because jack dorsey
but you know so now you've got youtube
who has finally decided to step into the
fray
of labeling and deciding what content is
what and making affirmative statements
about whether things are true or not
right they clearly don't care about the
sources because they're just citing
whatever they want
whenever they want yeah and this is a
stupid move for youtube you know why
because they were doing this behind the
scenes anyway yeah they're manipulating
it through the algorithms anyway
um we saw that with the tulsi gabbard
situation going on where you would
search steven crowder changed my mind
abortion and an old pbs video would
would
right yeah you know the problem got
fixed uh
so this is something that i think
they've overreached again because
they're trying to virtue signal to
people out there who are saying why
aren't you doing more
listen this is i'll tell you this this
has already been going on on youtube you
know it anyone who's been following
anyone who's been
trying to search for content know that
this has been going on but youtube has
to do more to appease
the radical left and here we are now
they've tipped their hand uh we're going
to have to leave youtube very soon but
first let's check back in with our
uh local entomologist on his quest for
uh japanese killer hornets even brendan
let us pray in silence
one goal tree climbing thomas jay
his face hurts and where is his glasses
he can't see without his glasses
put his glasses on put on his glasses
you know i hate to yeah i hate to
mention in her time of grieving but she
didn't get the name right or no he
doesn't wear glasses
but uh we'll check on even brendan i'm
sure that we'll see more of him sometime
soon we're actually about to go talk
about the big financial backers for
biden oh boy
dark money in politics well that's not a
thing anymore but we'll make it a thing
and uh we don't want to be fact checked
here on youtube because you know it's
going to be really hard and so we'll
just get banned so youtube
will make your life easy right now
everyone else go to my club we'll be
taking your chat right now you do
piss off